I've already issued a statement this
morning apologizing unreservedly for
traveling away from my home our
restrictions were in place as well as
this weekend it's important to be clear
that I also was there that last weekend
with my husband I did not follow the
advice I'm giving to others I'm truly
sorry for that I've seen a lot of the
comments from members of the public on
Twitter today people calling me a
hypocrite people telling me about the
hardships they've endured while
following my guidance my office has also
received emails from members of the
public who are making clear to me their
disappointment and unhappiness at what
I've done people have told me that I'm
irresponsible
that I've behaved as if my advice does
not apply to me I want people to know
that I have seen all of that and I've
heard the comments what I did was wrong
I'm very sorry it will not happen again
I know how important the advice is that
I've issued I do not want my mistake to
distract from that I don't want to make
the jobs of the police or my NHS
colleagues any harder and I apologize to
them as well I have a job to do as chief
medical officer to provide advice to
ministers on the path of this virus and
to support the medical profession as
they work night and day to save lives
this was a mistake
human error and there's no excuses I
should not have done what I did I'm very
sorry about that I've spoken to the
police this morning about this and I'm
sorry for taking up their time on this
when it could have been avoided having
spoken with the First Minister this
morning my intention is to continue to
focus on my job